I'm from Sweden I work for George Foster
of your world I would like to thank you
have been posted for the question
businesses now I don't think they get
enough attention from parents from
investors and others in most developing
countries small businesses are actually
making up the majority of the economy's
the DB and employment law I think it's
more on how we get attention a gig is
more imagine how we make involvement is
Gorman how do we facilitate I register
themselves so they making it easier
access to credit is there access to
contacts to figure businesses so they
can flow and together we are very
economies really thank you